Have you been watching? Uh,
Chernobyl there's one more episode left mini series and I'm hooked
on it, dude. And it's really good. Really good.
It's it's there's it's sometimes it's a little, you're like, wow,
it's a little much with the realism.
It's like a K I'm not watching a documentary, right?
You don't need to show a guy.
W I'm literally looking at a guy and he's only teeth and eyeballs,
but it's so good. And it's so gray. They only,
the only color in it is gray.
And nobody's talking in Russian accents, which is super weird to me.
Here's the thing. I love the show. It's great.
And now I'm going to make fun of it. Um,
uh, I heard the guy, the creator, the writer talking about it. He was like,
well, we chose not to do a Russian accent because, uh,
a Russian accent can be really comical. If, if,
if you're not careful and it's like, no, accent is only comical.
If you make a comical dude, if you, they put Russian X,
these guys is face because we're falling off and in the, in the documentary.
And you're like, Oh no, they're shooting the animals. Cause they're radioactive.
And you're like, Oh no, you think because someone's like,
you'll have to shoot the animal. We're going to be like, ah,
no. So they're not talking. Here's the other thing too.
If you're going to abandon them, talking in Russian accent, first of all,
having you speak Russian and make it subtitles. If you were going for realism,
all right. If you're not doing that, you have them speak the Russian accent.
If you're not doing that, okay, then just have them just be
their regular accent or, or, or whatever the. This is an American show. Right?
So, but they're not, some of the guys are Irish. Some of the guys are Swedish.
Some of the guys who are, literally British it, it makes me,
it takes me out of it. For sure. When they're like, when it's like in Russia,
what we're going to do, everyone's faces are fallen off comrade. What?
It's like, I thought guys, literally blood and bones, comrade.
You're like, what,
What guys got a third arm growing out of his forehead. Comrade.
I just saw a dog with no snout and an extra deck on his
comrade.
Well, we kind of do, Oh,
I got a night. What's Russia.
What's Russian food. I mean,
how bad is Russian food that I don't even know one Russian food for
real. What are traditional Russians foods? Oh Jesus.
Oh, abortion. Of course SU this. This is how you know Russian food sucks, dude.
Third, one down sweet and sour cabbage.
Look at this beef stroganoff. Those are the two I know. That's it.
Borst and beef stroganoff. Look at what they get.
What goes from the down from after that? What goes down? Sweet and sour cabbage.
Least. I know what it is then from then on. It's just,
you figure it out right here. So Yanka soup.
I feel like that has like literal screws in it and like bolts.
And you're like, what the? And they're just like, eat up.
It's good for the good you eat. You get strong. You eat the bolts. Go in.
Your body become part of you eat.
Now here's another one. Go, go look up.
See galaxy. Literally nothing else. Just you who knows it could be
goat. have no idea. It literally could be goat,
and dirt. Eat up. Galop ski. Go up.
See what is it?
Go Dick and dirtied it with [inaudible]
. You'd be big and strong. You have got Dick and bolts in you. Olivia. Olivia, Olivia is another one. Blini I think I've heard of that. Potato
Oak Roche. [inaudible]
potato [inaudible]. Wow. That's that's some real soundings food. Um,
beef stroganoff, dude. My roommate used to make beef stroganoff and I used to be like,
Oh
dude, it looks like someone took a on a place. A plate of pasta beef stroganoff, AKA dump on pasta evacuation, pasta, sweet and sour cabbage. That's the only thing that, by the way,
it
looks kind of good. The Russian food cabbage cooked in red wine, vinegar, Apple sauce, butter and onions. I don't know about all that diced apples, sugar Bailey. Yeah. It's really sweet. Sounds like
solid Yanka soup. Hearty soup made from thick chunks of beef and pork of Della
bang and actually garlic too. You put garlic on something it's over. I'll leave
it at all. I, I swear to God, put Chloe put garlic all over your deck. I'll
eat it. I don't give a. I have clothes for your balls. I man, I'm in dude
. Look at this, go Lipsey
. This. This looks terrible. Shredded or minced beef wrapped in cabbage sip
with cabbage dude, Russia. They're just like we have it. Put it in everything.
That's gross.
Yeah. Russians like to add some sour cream on top, you know,
Lew this ill or Livy. Olivie potatoes,
bologna eggs. I mean just all of it.
And carrots swimming in a bowl of mail. I don't like when people use
words that shouldn't be in the description like swimming. No,
they're not doing laps. Dude. Potatoes, pickles,
bologna eggs and carrots, bubblegum, rice,
Krispie treats water and Castro.
GT swimming in a bowl of may.
Yo what does it taste like?
Is the most quintessential of all Russian salads.
Every cook has his own recipe and it's stapled for every Russian
blini thin crepe like pancakes made from unleavened
dough. Yeah. Okay. That looks fine. Oh wow.
Potato Oak or Grushka that looks horrible. Oh, a cold soup. Hey, by the way.
Soup hot.
This Despacito. Any cold soup dude,
soup cold should be a drink. Anything cold.
I'm putting in my mouth and it's liquid. So drink.
I'm drinking it soup cold soup. You're lazy, dude. Heat it up.
Putting a microwave. It doesn't taste good like that. Then don't make it.
[Inaudible].
W a cold soup made from buttermilk gross
potatoes and onions.
Gross garnished with deal
gross. There's you call this potato breath.
Be bad as you call this potato coming out. The other end, smelling better.
Hey.
Hey potato. Of course. Hey. Wow.
This smells like awful donkey balls. How do we make it?
Smell better. Eat that then. it out. Oh, okay. Winter.
All right, here we go. Oh, here's here's another one.
Nish Nish use pronounce the K Cornish.
What is it? Mashed potatoes, ground beef,
onions and cheese filled inside thick dough, pastry and deep fried. I mean,
they just design that to try and be the best pasting possible thing. Ever.
King Cali.
Dumplings of ground beef and cilantro. I love cilantro, bro.
I'll eat it like a snack. Some people think it tastes like soap. I think.
I mean, how many it's like the top? How many?
Top 17. 18. Chuck. Chuck.
Didn't try with the name.
Deep fried balls or little logs of unloving to dough. I mean,
trying to make it sound so bad. Chalk chalk.
So these are deep fried balls or little logs. Enjoy.
I love comments, dude. Look at this idiot.
King Kali and catch Puri are Georgian food, not Russian. Okay.
Well, Russia was definitely around Biff. Was it around before Georgia? Probably.
Right. My, how long, how old is Russia?